for Edwin Catmull attorney to Rose and
your star and their pioneering work on
subdivision surfaces the Academy
presents an upgrade a scientific and
engineering award gentlemen please come
to the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all I have a new high
technology for teleprompters well that
works better this way my first class in
graduate school was in computer graphics
and it completely changed my life my
project was to make a film of my left
hand being animated and I then went on
to do my PhD work in rendering curved
surfaces but I knew at the time that the
techniques for representing organic
shapes really sucked so I was trying to
come up with a different way there was a
side project and you know maybe two
years later in 1973 I finally had an
idea that I thought would work and I
wrote it up
18 pages of engineering green note paper
with the proof and he gave it to one of
my professors who was one of the
originators of NURBS and he looked at it
briefly and he tossed it back to me he
said dad what is this Chet
so I put it to the side for a while and
three years later Jim Clark and I wrote
a paper on it and then I went pretty
much silent for a long period of time
but the reality is as we develop
representing organic surface this still
sucked and a lot of people are starting
to look at it
tony was leading this group Charles came
out of that group and there was a lot of
excitement and I'm I know that Tony then
starting with this idea added some
pieces to it that were important which
having do with creasing and making it
more useful and then Yost came along and
was able to prove something and give
representations which mathematically he
could connect it with the other tools
that we had Tony joined us at Pixar and
his first project was to put it into our
filmmaking process for Jerry's game
which was just meant to be a test of new
technology but it was so successful that
before that the store was over they for
people making bug's life grabbed it and
use it for all the organic shapes in and
bugs life and then Randleman adopted it
and then it became open-source this is
for me this incredible journey
never could predicted any of it I know
that it started at 46 years ago with an
idea and sometimes it just takes a lot
of really smart people working on it
from different points of view in
different places and a lot of patience
and if you do that and you can end up
with something that works I'm very
grateful to the SciTech Committee for
recognizing this I'm grateful for all
the wonderful people along the way and
of course the magnificent abilities
Tony and yolks thank you very much
I'd first like to thank my wife Cindy
she really sacrificed her career so that
I can do what I do
and I can't thank you enough for that it
mentioned there were lots of
contributors along the way I'd like to
thank several of my really important
co-authors I'm thinking of Michael Cass
Thien Truong Mark Halstead and Hughes
Hoppe I'd also like to thank the SciTech
and the debts committee I know how much
work this is so I thank you for your
diligence I know there was a lot of
history to plow through finally I'd like
to thank ed for creating an atmosphere
at Pixar an atmosphere really around the
whole computer graphics industry that
allowed this kind of work to happen and
finally I just like to mention that you
know I grew up in the age of Apollo and
so that really inspired me to go into
math and science and engineering we
don't have that today we don't have
those big exciting public projects but
we do have this industry and this
industry is an inspiration to so many
youngsters out there so please keep
doing what you're doing
[Music]
I'll try to be brief first I would like
to thank the Academy for giving me this
award secondly I want to thank the
company I used to work for called alias
the people behind Maya yeah exactly and
so 20 years ago when I was in the shadow
office we were looking at subdivision
surfaces and we they were considered as
something very strange okay and our goal
is to make them practical and so I'm
very fortunate to have been part of this
group and eventually went into my ins
very nice to see that it has been
adopted in many products in many movies
secondly I want to thank my family my
parents obviously wouldn't be here
without them and they gave me a great
kickstart in life they let me do art
first and then my older brother told me
to learn how to program yeah it was a
very cynical he said you know you might
get a good job for the summer and then I
got hooked and it's also why I'm here
sort of combined my interest in art and
science and my science degrees went up
as a consequence actually this award is
dedicated to him fortunately it's not
with us anymore last but not least I'm
going to thank my lovely daughter and
wife who were here for their love of
course and for putting up with me it's
not easy and I want to thank you guys
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
is that your wife who gave up her career
for that's you please can we give her a
round of applause
beautiful so beautiful unfortunately
that's all the time we have but before
we pop I know I feel the same but before
we part I'd like to take a moment to
recognize all the hard work you do
behind the cameras and the computers
this business of filmmaking has always
been rooted in the science of capturing
an image and projecting it onto a screen
everyone here keeps that heritage alive
but also we've just seen how you move
the technology forward and aspire to
make things better because we can always
do better it's been fun and a thrill and
I can honestly say congratulations you
are all winners tonight
thank you and good evening
[Applause]